regardez cette tablette que je vous
présente aujourd'hui alors on va parler
de la marque oppo avec sa tablette sa
tablette qui est pas toute nouvelle qui
a été présenté il y a quelques mois
c'est là oppo pad air alors pourquoi
est-ce que je vous parle de cette
tablette je vous dis tout de suite on
est dans une tablette milieu de gamme
mais cette tablette peut être
intéressant pour vous pourquoi parce que
la marque oppo est une marque qui monte
qui étoffe son catalogue avec de plus en
plus de produits et c'est la première
fois qu'on vient retrouver en France en
tout cas et bien une tablette de la
marque oppo vous allez voir que cette
tablette elle est intéressante pour
plusieurs raisons déjà le prix le
positionnement et en plus de ça elle
vient vraiment et elle vient travailler
avec votre smartphone et c'est justement
ce qui va nous intéresser alors vous
êtes prêt on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors regardez déjà je vous montrer
rapidement la boîte c'est joli c'est
clair on vous met le pad moi ce que j'ai
trouvé vachement rigolo parce que c'est
rigolo mais en tout cas ça m'a
interloqué c'est parce que vous voyez
pas du tout la barque au pot
généralement une marque elle veut se
mettre en avant elle veut qu'on voit que
c'est elle et ben là non donc là vous
voyez effectivement une tablette vous
voyez pas de leur masque quand je vois
pas ça me fait souvent penser à
iPad alors peut-être parce que la marque
iPad de Apple est beaucoup plus forte
c'est un pad c'est une tablette bon des
pâtes il y en a plein pour toi
dénomination pas de notamment chez
Xiaomi et qu'on sort donc bon rien de
surprenant pour trouver le oppo il faut
venir là donc ça c'est intéressant
vraiment d'un point de vue purement
stratégique comment est-ce que sur le
packaging ils viennent mettre leurs
marques vous voyez là j'ai le référence
du produit au pot pad air mais sinon
j'ai que oppo ici j'ai que oppo ici et
j'ai que pas d'ici j'ai même pas pas de
r allez savoir pourquoi ça montre un
truc ça montre que le nom pad R n'est
pas encore fort n'est pas encore connu
ne sert à rien que ce produit si vous
l'avez dans les rayons vous allez
retenir quoi vous allez retenir pas de
tablette tablette pad ok ça peut
m'intéresser je vais pas l'acheter
forcément pour la marque je veux acheter
parce que j'ai appris parce qu'il est
intéressant et je sais même pas si ce
produit est référence en magasin on peut
l'acheter sur le web d'ailleurs je vous
mets un lien dans la description vous
pouvez trouver chez Boulanger d'ailleurs
je vous dis le prix tout de suite
attendez j'ai ma feuille voilà tac le
jet feuille alors il y a deux versions
il y a une version 64 Go j'ai en tarif
269 € toujours susceptible d'évoluer en
fonction de l'endroit où vous le
trouverez et une version à 128 Go
normalement tu as 349 et qu'on peut
trouver à 299 € ça veut dire que à moins
de 300 balles normalement je viens avoir
une tablette Android on se parle bien
ici d'Android et vous allez voir que
c'est bien plus que ça parce qu'il y a
coloros derrière de ce truc qui est
vachement intéressant si vous connaissez
colorés sur les smartphones vous allez
probablement apprécier colorés pour pad
qui est juste ici donc ça c'est chouette
vous avez donc une tablette qui est
intéressante qui a pas mal de qualité
très honnêtement vu le tarif déjà on va
commencer par le design alors regardez
ce design ils ont ce qu'ils appellent le
oppo glow c'est ce petit côté légèrement
brillant alors bon c'est pas gloglo
glossiglossi comme on a pu voir ailleurs
mais bon ça brille un peu c'est un
espèce de petit gris en fait un
métallique je sais pas ce que c'est
comme on va mettre mon je pense que
c'est un petit plastique qu'on a mais
qui donne vraiment un côté métal et
c'est assez premium très sympa un effet
vague si ils aiment bien ce côté là chez
oppo bon après ça c'est peut-être mieux
qu'avoir un truc d'une seule maquillage
j'en sais rien la caméra qui est là la
marque qui est là les normes qui sont
planqués juste là en bas de la recharge
en USB C c'est classique hein on a une
batterie de 7100 millions d'erreurs et
alors le truc je vous lis tout de suite
il faut prendre votre mal en patience
ici vous avez un bloc de charge qui
fournirez que ça c'est bien mais c'est
de la charge 18 Watts alors sur le site
de oppo il vous marque de la recharge
rapide oui peut-être un peu pour un
smartphone mais pas des masses néanmoins
une tablette on a besoin de la recharger
comme on rechargerait un smartphone on
peut davantage prendre son temps donc ça
ça me dérange pas trop ça fonctionne
l'autonomie est plutôt bonne vous allez
monter jusqu'à 10h ça dépend soit
d'usage mix ça dépend ce que vous allez
en faire on peut nous annonce jusqu'à
15h en lecture de vidéo jusqu'à celle
Maxence c'est ce qu'ils annoncent bon il
faut quand même partir en dessous mais
est-ce qu'il est cool c'est que vous
avez un processeur de quoi le code c'est
un stand dragon 680 gravé en cyanomètre
je vous passe le truc on est ici sur du
milieu de gamme de chaque milieu de
gamme mais une fois de plus pour ce que
va venir faire cette tablette ça
fonctionne donc bon pas de mauvaise
surprise en tout cas autre petite
spécificité intéressante vous avez 4
giga de ram que vous pouvez venir
étendre virtuellement vous venez dans
RAM 4 giga de ram + 1 giga de ram alors
ça c'est de la RAM virtuelle en fait ce
que ça vient faire si vous le savez pas
l'arabe c'est la mémoire vive ça va vous
aider pour pas plus bon je vous passe un
peu technique on s'en fout un peu mais
comprenez que 4 Go de RAM alors on sait
pas une tablette qu'on va utiliser pour
faire des choses extrêmement pointues
n'a pas besoin de beaucoup de
performances mais si vous voulez un
petit peu plus de RAM et bien vous allez
taper dans la rom c'est en fait toute
votre stockage et vous allez pouvoir
créer de la RAM virtuelle donc vous
passez d'un 4 Go de RAM à lorsque vous
l'actionnez ici alors on est sur 4 g
vous montez à 5 Go de RAM vous montez à
6 giga de ram vous le montez à 7 giga de
ram vous voyez je suis bon en maths à
peu près le principe voilà on est
là-dedans donc il faut vraiment venir
garder ça ça va pas vraiment changer la
face du monde soyons clair mais ça peut
venir assouplir un peu l'expérience on
va retenir ça comme ça donc ça c'est
plutôt cool alors puisque je suis là et
on va y rester on va se parler de
l'expérience logiciel parce que c'est un
point fort chez oppo c'est color os
alors coloros c'est un truc déjà qui est
bien c'est comme son nom l'indiqué de
couleur au niveau des
icônes donc ça permet d'avoir vraiment
une très très belle lisibilité au niveau
de l'expérience donc ça c'est vraiment
très très chouette et puis surtout allez
assez loin notamment au niveau de la
personnalisation vous allez pouvoir
venir changer pas mal de choses les
icônes le font derrière plan la forme
des icônes les couleurs la taille des
polices bref donc on peut venir un peu
personnaliser l'histoire je trouve ça
très très cool alors ici il faut savoir
que on est sur une tablette avec un taux
de rafraîchissement de 60 hertz donc on
va pas pouvoir venir choisir son taux de
rafraîchissement on est sur du
soixantaine c'est la base donc pas plus
pas moins ça donne quoi ce truc en fait
ça sera très bien pour tout ce qui va
être divertissement regardez des films
regarder des séries sur Netflix mycanal
Disney plus tout ce que vous voulez ça
va c'est correct la qualité est bonne on
est en plus de ça sur une dalle IPS
c'est du LCD on va pas avoir des noirs
profonds comme on l'aurait sur de l'eau
laine mais une fois de plus on est à
moins de 300 balles donc on va pas tout
attendre donc bon on reste quand même
sur un truc qui est maîtrisé un truc qui
est limité on a suffisamment de
performances et de fluidité pour me
faire tourner des petits jeux vous voyez
là j'ai mis par exemple un asphalt 9 qui
tournera et il y a pas de souci ça
fonctionne bien mais il y a certains
jeux où on sera un peu limité donc il
faut le savoir donc c'est une tablette
pour le quotidien pour venir faire un
peu de bureautique pour faire ses mails
sur le net par là-dessus moi je suis
plus sur ordi mais on peut venir gérer
des mails là dessus sans problème on
peut venir également faire des
réservations des voyages voilà faire
plein de petits trucs mais on va pas
avoir la tablette la plus performante du
monde ça il faut vraiment le savoir ça
permet d'avoir une tablette du quotidien
et surtout ce qui est cool avec cette
tablette c'est cet écran parce que
regardez en terme de prise en main c'est
vachement bien ça se prend très très
bien en main alors bon il faut des très
grands mains si vous voulez le tenir
comme ça mais c'est pas le sujet on est
quand même sur une dalle de 10,36 pouces
ça reste grand ça reste correct en plus
de ça je la trouve pas très lourde elle
fait 440 g elle est bien équilibrée au
niveau du poids donc il y a rien de
déconnant ici le truc qui est bien c'est
la résolution on est sur deux cas
chouettes après sur une tablette comme
ça il vaut mieux l'écran quand même
grand donc si vous êtes sur une
résolution inférieure ça va dégrader
l'expérience on a donc 2000 pixels ici
et 1200 pixels alors après la densité de
pixel est pas folle folle 225 pixels par
pouce et par moment on va le voir
lorsque vous baladez j'en sais rien moi
je vais mettre là sur Youtube ça se voit
un peu sur des miniatures sur des choses
mais si vous vous mettez un film si vous
vous mettez une série pour moi il y a
rien de déconnant il y a rien de
dérangeant là-dessus je vous parlais
tout à l'heure de tout ce qui était
performance alors on s'en doutera une
fois de plus vulgarie fait vu le
positionnement ils viennent maîtriser la
chose la technodrame c'est de la LPD r4x
qui fonctionne bien attention ça va très
bien c'est une fois de plus qu'on va
retrouver usuellement sur cette gamme-là
donc pas de mauvaise surprise le
stockage la techno c'est de l'UFS 2 ça
va c'est correct on peut venir augmenter
son stockage jusqu'à 512 Go donc si
jamais vous arrivez à saturation bon
pour mettre un petit peu plus je vous
recommande pas nécessairement la version
64 Go parce que 64 Go si vous aimez bien
installer plein d'applis et que vous
leur mettez un peu dans la gueule ça
peut abondant de coincer un petit peu
alors il y a l'extension effectivement
mais mieux vaut rajouter un peu d'argent
je vous dis là vous mettez 30 euros de
plus et vous doublez votre stockage donc
le 128 Go pour moi c'est quand même un
truc à venir réfléchir d'autant plus
avec ce tarif là au lieu de 349 vous
l'aviez 299 ne soit plus les liens sont
en bas donc ça c'est cool alors il y a
un autre sujet donc faut que je vous
parle c'est tout ce qui va être audio on
va se mettre une de mes vidéos je vous
aime beaucoup parler de oppo cette
semaine c'est pas fait exprès mais ce
produit je voulais vous en parler quand
même avant la fin de l'année et comme le
finding 5 Pro c'est le smartphone de
l'année pour moi et que en plus je vous
parlais de leur smartphone pliant le fin
graines de flip qui va arriver l'année
prochaine vous voyez ça fait beaucoup
d'actu sur repos mais c'est chouette
alors regardez on va se mettre ça et on
va écouter un peu le son avec
l'arrivée avec le truc c'est que vous
avez des haut-parleurs qui vont sortir
de là de là de là mais également de la
alors c'est très compliqué pour vous à
vous rendre compte comme ça le truc est
assez dingue je vous explique pourquoi
mais le truc qui est bien si vous voulez
hop là c'est toi monsieur gros le truc
qui est bien c'est que ça vient pas
énormément spatialisé mais vraiment du
son qui vient un peu tous les côtés donc
ça c'est cool le truc qui est un peu
moyen mais une fois de plus dans cette
gamme de prix ça me dérange pas le son
est assez médium très clairement donc si
vous l'écoutez comme ça vous allez
saigner des oreilles si je baisse la
moitié j'entends vraiment pas grand
chose il faut que je sois dans un
environnement très maîtrisé parce que
sinon le son est pas énorme j'entends un
peu mais bon après moi je gueule très
honnêtement c'est normal et ça
manquerait un poil de puissance et puis
surtout ça va manquer d'avoir un spectre
un peu plus large un peu plus de rondeur
on est vraiment sur le médium vous voyez
un peu comme ça et ces trucs qui est des
fois un peu dommage donc ce que vous
pouvez faire c'est venir mettre alors
vous l'avez pas inclus avec mais ça vaut
le coup de venir le faire c'est de venir
soit brancher ici avec un petit
accessoire usb-c Jack pour venir
brancher un casque en filaire si vous
voulez sinon vous vous connectez en
Bluetooth vous avez du Bluetooth
un point et c'est là où vous allez
maximiser l'expérience alors après vous
avez tous les codecs qui vont bien SBC
assez APTX ça PTX HD et du l-dack donc
on a ici quoi faire donc quel que soit
votre casque si vous avez même un super
casque de Sony et bien vous pouvez venir
l'utiliser ici pas de problème donc ça
c'est cool l'autre truc qui est un peu
limite c'est la luminosité 360 nitres
regardez alors une fois de plus ici pas
forcément évident de vous en rendre
compte mais je le trouve pas extrêmement
lumineux donc si vous allez à
l'extérieur ça peut être aussi un peu la
limite du truc mais une fois de plus on
a un bruit de 300 balles donc bon je
peux pas tout avoir par contre ce qui
est bien c'est que cet écran est
certifié par toys Island venant lutter
contre la lumière bleue donc ça c'est
chouette on a du wifi 5 alors vous avez
des petites caméras vous le voyez alors
pour moi les tablettes et caméras on
s'en fout un peu globalement c'est
vraiment histoire de venir se marrer en
fait vous avez une petite caméra à
l'arrière là qui est planqué juste ici
là vous voyez caméra là c'est une caméra
de 8 mégapixels on ouvre à F 2.0
histoire 2 vraiment histoire de et vous
avez une caméra de selfie qui est juste
ici c'est du sac mégapixel on ouvre F
deux points 2 donc voilà un peu pour
toute cette expérience globale
maintenant le truc qui est vraiment
intéressant et ça ça va je pense vous
plaire qu'en fait sur cette tablette il
y a un truc qui est génial c'est que
vous pouvez faire de la collaboration
multi-écran je mets les grandes
guillemets quand je dis ça vous prenez
votre smartphone Android si vous prenez
un smartphone vidéo pour savoir plaisir
au pot et vous venez le connecter
directement le truc qui est cool alors
j'en ai malheureusement pas ici tout de
suite à vous montrer mais en fait ça va
venir afficher la fenêtre de votre
smartphone ici et vous allez pouvoir
directement sur votre tablette taper
dans votre tablette et taper dans votre
smartphone donc répondre à vos messages
directement ici en plus de ça cette
fonctionnalité elle est cool pourquoi
vous pouvez faire des copier-coller vous
vous copiez du texte dans votre tablette
vous le collez directement dans votre
smartphone et réciproquement c'est grâce
au système du presse-papier très facile
de faire glisser déposer des images d'un
côté et de l'autre ça ça marche bien et
également utiliser la connexion Internet
de votre smartphone comme un petit modem
ici vous venez partager très facilement
bon bref ils ont optimisé le système et
ça permet de faire connecter vos
appareils Android ensemble donc ça une
fois de plus c'est très malin ça c'est
chouette donc on a une expérience qui
est complète que vous souhaitiez
l'utiliser pour venir réserver vos
vacances pour regarder des films des
séries des petits jeux pas trop
gourmands pour gérer vos emails pour
écrire à Tati pour faire ce que vous
voulez et bien je trouve que cette
tablette est pas mal et une fois de plus
c'est la première à arriver en France
dans l’écosystème au pot écosystème qui
se développe avec très beau smartphone
avec un smartphone qui se plie qui va
arriver l'année prochaine avec l'OPO
watch peut-être d'autres Pow watch qui
va arriver l'année prochaine avec des
écouteurs les enco donc ça c'est cool
donc on a une gamme qui se développe et
ça c'est sur l'écosystème elle est forte
parce que ce soit chez oppo que ce soit
chez Xiaomi que ce soit chez Honor que
ce soit chez Samsung que ce soit chez
beaucoup et bien on va retrouver des
écosystèmes et c'est tout l'enjeu des
marques aujourd'hui de venir vous
proposer le maximum de produits vous
rentrez par smartphone et après vous
vendre tout le reste alors même si les
marques préfèrent que vous preniez tous
les produits de la même marque avec une
optimisation néanmoins c'est Android ça
marche c'est ouvert et ça c'est chouette
voilà donc moi je trouve plutôt cool
cette tablette une fois de plus elle est
lourde d'être parfaite mais elles sont
tarif je la trouve vraiment très honnête
et je trouve qu'une fois de plus au pot
fait du bon travail donc si vous
recherchez une tablette à un tarif
maîtrisé il va plus jouer le lien je
vous le redis la version 64 Go et en ce
moment chez Boulanger il a 269 et la
version 128 à 299 tous les liens sont en
bas voilà donc comme ça vous savez tout
on reparlera l'année prochaine de peau
avec les fight x 6 fines 6 pro et les
finden de flip voilà s'il pouvait
améliorer un peu les nombres les rendre
un peu moins un coucher dehors ça
m'arrangerait merci au pot même si je
sais que tout le monde ne m'écoutera pas
et que il s'en foutent bien évidemment
donc je vous embrasse prenez soin de
vous passez de bonnes fêtes si vous
regardez cette vidéo avant les fêtes et
si vous la regardez après vous allez
ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]